we
spoke about
trusting your calculation
that's what we said
and we have shown several
positions games actually
two games in
particular
that the kings we shown one game of none
that the king marched all the way to f5
all here and then
white won the game quite quickly
and we've shown another game between
really two of the best players in the
world
gashimov against
gilishuk
that black's king
made it all the way something like
this
and he won the game you know this game
julian
it's very
you know what i
you see but
if you weren't here last week and didn't
see it
thanks to our
important part of our production ban you
can see it on our channel
as many as
many others
of my funny shows and other grandmaster
educational shows right now we are a
team you know like lasser and var and
others
do serious chess and we the
entertainment part
but i said that we will continue tiny
bit with
this idea and i was thinking today
well
i had some other games that i was
thinking maybe of showing but then i was
thinking you know this is probably one
of the best games
ever in history
although it has one flaw
because power said that it's probably
his best game and considering that he is
maybe the best player
maybe it's a lot
his game against opal do you know this
game julian
okay this one you know and the other one
you have to go to our youtube channel
and watch it
but it's cool okay so this is between
kasparov and topal the funny part the
interesting part is that topalov himself
is really fearless as well like many of
his game are as wild as possible
he
really trusts
whatever he feels about the position
sometimes he's actually gambling too
much
but that's how what i wanted to show you
last week and today
whatever dangerous the position is
if you believe in that
well you should go with it
so this was played there about well 14
15 years ago almost you know actually in
next month we're going to
vacancy is going to start another
tournament
this is in vacancy
to 1999.
okay playing the periods
no no big not really important to
see the opening although isabel is
moving the pieces on the bottom we will
move it slow for her so she can get the
position
okay
queen d2
basically white is going more or less
too
well you were here last week right when
we spoke about the king marching
no
really it's like amazing okay
we are having here a structure that
opposition that's very s
quickly going to be like the english
attack white is going to play f3
long castle g4
similar ideas in the sicilian that's
when bishop e3 is being played
okay c6 f3 okay because power also
understand that
b5
knight g2 okay
there are many possibilities here like
g4 cast whatever knight g2
knight bd7
black is tiny bit delaying castle why
delays castle because it gives
impossibility in some situations to
castle the other way if you will castle
hill bishop 86 h4 well of course it's a
main post major possibility but
bishop h6
take take
bishop b7
a3 okay very soon we will
get to our
important position
e5
okay quite logical
by the way why a3 was played well to
prevent black from expanding on
the queen side
long castle
queen e7
which move is quite normal in those in
such positions
so white yeah i mean newcastle's long
well how to continue
d5 you mean yeah that's a possibility
but black just might capture and you
open the file for him or maybe black
will play six it's a possibility but
well
many times just moving the king to a
safety you know moving the king away
from to defend the pawns if something
happens moving it away from a c file
that sometimes gets to open okay king b1
is kind of almost safe automatic move
a6 i wonder if in this position
a5 actually would be a move that
i think deserves serious attention
like i'm not certain why
why if y5 wasn't played
houdini's first choice a5
i just i just checked okay
no it's just logical because i i was
just thinking during if he played a3 to
stop before okay so i'll play five to
play before
okay
well available for classes at the st
louis chess club
all right a6
now very strong positional maneuver that
actually we see in some in the damage
very variation of the king's indian like
i'm not going to show exactly but there
is
very pretty
hole here
one day
if we can get
our knight
that's that's a really decent square
knight to see one the in the damage
there are some ideas like that
castle knight b3
capture
capture okay we are just getting to that
the interesting position
c5 and back so it's really interesting
this position
on one hand okay so what we have here
it's kind of bizarre to see black's king
where
his pawns are
so much advanced right it means that his
king is
somewhat weak
on the other hand he has quite nice
development
and all the pieces are
well all the pieces are out and he also
controls some space it's like if white
rook would have been here no okay it
would be nicer to say hey white has all
these pieces in nice squares but it
doesn't
knight b6
well black wants to play d5
g3 interesting idea
the bishop going to
h3
king moving same same way that why play
king b1 those are very safe solid simple
moves
knight to a5
bishop back
to a8
bishop
d5
okay
quite
a lot is happening already many pawns in
the center
but
i'm kind of moving quickly because the
action is just going to start one of the
greatest games ever
check
and rookie one
they mention a line of capture capture
and white might use this outpost for his
for his knight to jump
blacking is a bit vulnerable
for example and if take
and black is lost
life just lost the game
yep
no okay black doesn't have to lose
immediately but black played the move d4
jump
knight take
ok
this is
one of the most amazing positions ever
ever
the sparrow sacrifice not one rook but
two rooks and believe it or not i'll
give you a heads up black king
got checkmated or he lost almost a lot
of material
when black king was here
made all the way
to d1
this move
we will start seeing the ideas it's
beyond incredible what is happening here
the dark spot about this game
is that this combination is not perfect
it's not perfect actually black has a
refutation and those are okay those are
two of the best players in the world
they didn't play that i wonder what
kasparov by the way would have played
after
we will see taking the look of course
it's our most critical line right we
just had our previous lecture about
material captures four signals all those
things so of course this will be the
main thing but actually the correct move
for black would have been to play
this insane unbelievable move
king b6
attacking the knight and getting the
king
out of danger in some lines
for example if the queen goes here
you don't want to take
the work
taking the look
i'm going to take the knight and if this
is going to take this knight
and if this
gonna take this one
and if king take white's knight it will
transpose to similar versions of the
game
but let me just go back
if
just take is a very powerful move
in
crazy position under attack
bizarre spot
where is the king
but
computers say that black is actually
better in this position
and some other lines that are in this
position are
playing this incredible move before
once again it is impossible to take the
rook
take take
only move check
and winning
impossible to take the
impossible to take the work
but
but
he took the book immediately
now what to play
second book is being sacrificed
but cannot be taken
if take
okay this is your power to tell me what
what
is playing here
let's follow the forcing moves
take the pawn on default check
okay king has to go here only move
bless you
queen check on with square
block and now and then you check with at
the end of the night
and actually checkmate on the next move
forget about the queen
king eighth queen is seven so forget the
queen
and if this move
forget the queen checkmate
so impossible to take
now
why why not take immediately
because of
some line like this and now
black can give the knight his forcing
exchanges here that's not okay not so
great for white white is down a full
look
so i played check
the knight cannot block because the
queen is under attack right you cannot
interpose over there
okay king b6
take
yeah queen blocking
just not working i mean they have some
complicated lines but even material wise
white already got enough here he has a
piece and two pawns
but we are going to see the adventure
okay
now think about it this is not some
you know i don't know uh
bug house game starring julian and
several of the other heroes up there
right
although it might look like it
but look this topalov became world
champion in
2005 winning big was the highest rated
player in the world for few years
so
no joke those are really really the
best players best players out there
and because powerful caspar
you don't see the king on you don't see
the king on a4 that many times
okay quincy tree
now they have some
analysis
saying that
some ideas about the 2k7 might have been
a better move
but it's not very clear actually
i i do not agree with that big analysis
i think that the wake of power played is
very strong
but
queen
okay threatening checkmate
white is down a rook and a piece so if
he's not going to really checkmate black
it's not really okay it's really scary
to play that position when you are for
both players
i mean topalov was kind of forced into
this position well he actually had one
possibility to play king b6
for white
if white is not going to check meteor
oh basically win the queen
he's pretty much going to lose the game
okay so he's threatening checkmate
well queen b3 is checkmate
what happens if bishop take
i'm sorry
but well yes he's preventing this move
which move
king b2
and what's your idea with king b2
excellent
oh my gosh yes amazing and doesn't
matter what black plays look at this
position isn't this
one form fairy tales
look at that i mean this is unbelievable
unbelievable
okay so quintet
what's the difference if king to b2
then
exchanging queens and that's not really
nice
right dif exchanging is the best method
of defense you just you just get rid of
the
attacking pieces
all right
okay seven
okay threatening a checkmate
bishop b7 why not
why not look d6 okay why to defend with
the bishop
you have the same checklist
but we said king the queen d4 before
but that's the thing the rook
is overloaded because he's defending a6
and he cannot support d4
no you just take
exactly
so that's why the rook basically
basically the rook is already
occupied by
defending the queen on d4 against
king b2 so b should be seven
take
now there are many many possibilities in
this position
many possibilities
of course to take the work is
checkmate immediately
so which moves would make sense if you
are black in this position which would
make sense here to play
after that
rook b8 okay but what is white's threat
think about that
rook b8 and if i will play this with
this idea
no
not now so the rule cannot really move
anywhere
so how you defend such position how to
defend in general one you exchange the
opponent attacking pieces
two
you bring defenders
right you bring defenders
so
let's say we want to bring this one
in the game to power plate queen c4 we
will see in a second
uh
straightening checkmate
this move
now comes one of the most unbelievable
move ever i mean i can
the fact that kasparov has seen this
move is
beyond unbelievable
look
this is an
idea to to drive the queen away
but quincy 4 is possible
this move is is really
inhumane i mean i i i think that he saw
it at least at some point but i really
think it's quite
unbelievable
basically now he wants to be able to
play this move and drive
black screen away
i mean just that move
rook d6
and drive the
queen away
and
the game is completely completely over
in this position
because by the way this move immediately
rook d6 right now
so this is incredible
just the idea of d6 unbelievable i mean
quincy fall
take
okay still threatening checkmate
okay
the best line you know i i always say
that there is no checkmate in chess
right i mean i've said it in many
lectures here and this what what do i
mean by that
that
on most attacking games
doesn't matter how unbelievable they are
there's some way for the defender
to give back material avoid checkmate
and be in a reasonable spot okay not
giving away queen
but like i said it many times like
sacrifice is an investment
you basically say hey take a work
i'm attacking you
i think that to avoid checkmate you will
need to give me
six points okay so i want one point
right that's basically the idea of
sacrifice very few sacrifices is really
okay check me i mean at high level most
of the time there are ways to defend and
even in this
most unbelievable incredible
game
it's no no exception
look best line
suggested by a computer it's rook d1
king b2
okay needs to defend against checkmate
threatening checkmate again
exchange
take take
take
a5
at the end of all this incredible line
if the king goes back
nothing going to take and if take
what's going to have three three
connected past pawns and a bishop for a
rook
right
so at the end of this incredible line
white is getting into a
rook endgame
with the pawn up and probably winning
look at black's king and the pawns over
there so the end of this incredible
checkmate idea and sacrifice and
brilliant and everything whatever you
want to name it
the end of this
if black defend perfectly white is a
pawn up is still going to win the game
yeah
with perfect and this is really
important to understand many people are
sacrifice checkmate
very very rarely we have seen in the
world championship okay there was no
sacrifice how carlson defended that game
nine
and didn't get checkmated like but there
was no even no sacrifice but
okay the pilot took
check
and now which move
i will let you a tiny bit think and tell
me which move
would you think white should play so
kasparov played this
incredible move c3
and he really really had to see that
because if he doesn't long many moves
ago
because if he doesn't have those
possibilities if those possibilities do
not exist
is really in trouble actually we will
get to a position that is
beyond incredible one move
so now let's see
it's very simple to understand what's
happening if
king c5 no-brainer right what are we
gonna play
just win the queen i i don't need to
look for checkmate you know our brain
stops here
winning the queen stops
there is better
great
if this move
there are several ways to play here
what's what would you suggest i will let
you
suggest a good continuation here for
white there are several ways to win but
i just need one
i think i got it
shoot mike
perfect perfect perfect perfect and
and it's very important just the way of
thinking forcing move
in each of the lines that might
suggested black had
one move
it's very
simple
it's making our life much easier when we
have to see
a straight line i play this
this is a straight line as opposed to i
play this move okay you can go here here
here and then in each one here here then
you get
endless amount of possibilities this is
the power of forcing moves straight line
queen a2 by the way take on b5 also
winning but queen a2
check black has one move
queen b2 check black has one move
and we stop our calculation
and we stop it
i mean okay there's i think
rookie seven maybe even stronger some
alliance i don't know right wrong i
don't care about that bishop bishop f1
is winning and that's enough for us
okay keep queen take impossible so king
take
now
craziest line
check
okay
let's
see
if kd3 we will follow mike's idea and
play bishop f1 win the queen
king d2 was played in the game so we
will see it in a second
what if king b4
okay once again you know you're doing
this with me right so if not it will be
too boring
why to play how does white win here
and then okay let's say black black
plays king here
slowly
uh
okay we have to follow following lines
you will fall fast in line you will win
here
mike do you have idea yes uh
okay that's a start if k if king a4
checkmate if king c5 you're just gonna
take the queen right yeah rook c7 okay
so i'll go here okay now queen a3 queen
283 black has one move
and now
perfect
as long as you keep it in one lines it
will be easier okay
king to b3 is of course is of course
really checkmate white will play queen
b2 and then the king go here rook a7
checkmate so
only move
check
now here is the tricky part if black
king is going to step to e3 or e1 what
is right going to play
lacking is going to step to those
squares what would white play
you don't want to exchange
yeah it will just
remember if we said how to defend we
want to bring
more more more defenders
if white connects the rook with the
attack it's over
i mean if king take f3 queen g2 is
actually a cool checkmate
the if white will connect the rook
that's it it's over on the spot
okay
so king d1
amazing like seriously those are like
here they show you the path of the king
i mean in
world champion to become world champion
i mean this is
unbelievable
but you have to trust your calculation
like you know
our topic here and was was last week
if you're afraid if you're scared
despite that you see that it's good no
you have to play it you know you have to
play maximum you have you calculated
wrong you learn to calculate better
saying i'm scared is not anything in
those two people repertoire two players
but here came
unbelievable move i remember i analyzed
it quite deeply and looking at that and
the thing is that we are thinking in
this position
kasparov had to see this many moves
before many many moves before you don't
give a rooker who can a bishop for
your mood or feeling
so which move here
oh
you don't have the luxury of playing
such a move
no
no no i mean okay you're gonna be
checkmated immediately let's say
if you will play rookie 7
i will play check
what will you play you're going to move
your king here
okay let me move my rook
well i mean white king is not like in
safe heaven i mean look at white king
and it's not like that thousand pieces
on the boat here
i mean black wants to win in one move
that's the thing that white has one move
here one move not to resign but that's
the move that's winning if this move
wouldn't exist this would be a horrible
game but it's one of the greatest game
ever
mike you have an idea you're
looking at something
and which one is that
well i guess uh
bishop back to uh
f1 or f5 bishop back to f1
let's say bishop f4 f if f5 take if
bishop f1 at least you make right at
least i can check now
what happens if the queen goes
take well you're going to check hill
you play bishop f1 uh i probably want to
get the queen
i mean
c1 king e2 oh but i want to keep him off
of e2 so
uh-huh
and this move is unbelievable not to see
it here like mike said it very simply
there is only one way pretty much to get
away to get
back not to play queen d3
without this move
white is lost
lost but after this move
white is just winning this is just
checkmate
this is just checkmate
just check me no joke
this is just checkmate no joke
rook d2 was played
now
the amazing thing is that
you know why white is
winning this because of one thing well
white still
needs to find a move to play well what
to play here with white
if you take take
take take black is better actually okay
maybe it's a door checking might be a
draw what to play with white if you take
the queen it's going to take you
very good
that's your move right mike
it's incredible and why is white winning
white winning this game
well
threatening to take
but he's not winning because of
checkmate you know
if this rook you see this rook
this look was here
black is super okay
black is just gonna take maybe black is
better maybe draw
but white white is winning
because
white managed to win material no
checkmate there was no checkmate here if
the rook was on g8 they could be okay
so after all this unbelievable thing
the game is finished because of
well okay the rest is just technical
parts well still maybe some more but
okay resign because check here and the
pawns are falling and so on
this this is amazing
the moves bishop f1 especially bishop f1
to me i think like incredible
to see it many moves before and after
bishop f1 rook d7
you know with some players it might be
coincidence with kasparov you can
probably bet that
he had seen it and it's in it
many many moves before
yeah no this
that's why it's one of the greatest
attacking games ever but the important
thing is again
when you
when you
play something
and you believe your calculations
you know
you should stick to that doesn't matter
if it looks scary if it's a lot of
material
maybe for next week you know i'll show a
little bit about especially since
someone here saw me also
i actually never i don't think i ever
showed it here like the
tiny bit same idea
a bullet game that i played
that was not perfect but it was a bullet
game and it rocked it got like a lot a
lot of publicity because my opponent was
really strong and he got checkmated here
and it was a queen sacrifice so
something in that spirit although
the big difference is that combination
that i played was not a sound
combination in a normal game i would not
play that because there was a refutation
most likely
i would think for five or ten minutes
and see that but it turned out to be
some brilliancy because well there was
no great defense
in this game i mean of course it's best
players in the world and
almost perfect game the only
dark spot
was the move king v6 that topalov could
have played and he didn't have to enter
this
craziness
you